foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
football playoff was announced last
night
at least the the final six rankings
going into next week so who does fritzy
get for us
in my opinion the best college football
writer that's out there huge fan of Andy
Staples he covers college football for
the athletic of course
Andy thank you so much for coming on the
show now I know you played college
football at Florida do you have any epic
um epic shot to the nut stories either
personally or from a teammate play is a
relative term I was a human tackling
dummy but I will say like playing I was
an offensive lineman like you playing
along the line you don't get as many of
those like you get the occasional sack
tap
stuff happens in piles but you don't get
the high speed Collision down there like
that that story he just told like hockey
players are built different
no they definitely are there's no
question and you're right about that
people are like amazed when I tell them
football players don't wear cups I'm
like absolutely not I don't know anybody
yeah you can't look annoying it's it's
not in a good place for you to have it
so um yeah football players don't wear
Cuts but you're right you would think
that actually would be more more shots
to the cajones that I don't even know
what a cajon is
all I know is one time in my life I've
seen the uh that region referred to as
the Cajon so I'm trying to rack up as
many of them throughout the course of
the show as I can I I don't know if he
took Spanish at Princeton it's uh the
J's silent it's it's ponies uh and so
yes you're exactly right right my son
started playing tackle football first
and my wife's like well he needs to wear
a cuff for this right I'm like no God no
and then he starts playing lacrosse and
she's like so no cup here I'm like no no
he absolutely needs a cup for lacrosse
wait wait wait hold on a second so
number one is cojones
we've taught Ross something new today
all right
is cajones the Spanish term for your
balls oh no
yeah
oh my gosh so I kind of knew that but I
didn't know it was Spanish and I thought
you're doing a bit I didn't know if I
was walking into something no you know
what you know what so just everybody
knows at Princeton where I went to
school
supposedly number one school in the
country or whatever they make you take
three semesters of a foreign language
so I took something I took French
there's not more year and still didn't
remember that or know that that's
amazing well one one more Princeton
story for you because you tweeted out
this week that when you on on your
official visit to Delaware that they
played DJ cools Let Me Clear My Throat
for three straight hours which perfect
sense complete Banger in 1996. so in my
on my official visit to Princeton a year
earlier which is where I drank my first
beer by the way
they had the radio on in my host dorm
room for the entire time I heard space
hogs in the meantime
probably 27 times during my official
visit I cannot think of the ivy league
without thinking of spacehog now
that is amazing uh love it so we got to
get into the college football playoff
Andy let's just start with this okay
number one Georgia number two Michigan
number three TCU number four USC any
issues with that or even I can throw in
five Ohio State six Alabama any issues
with the currently ranked top six as it
sits right now I mean Alabama being
ahead of Tennessee they have the same
record and they played a game and
Tennessee won and boo Corrigan who's the
the chair of the Committees the NC State
A.D he got asked about it last night and
he's like well it was the way Tennessee
lost to South Carolina like no no boo
you gotta you got a built-in excuse here
just say it's because hen and hookers
hurt like say that that'll that'll fly a
lot better because you're ignoring an on
the field result and if you're just
gonna ignore the on-field result why
bother playing that game in the first
place let's just simulate them you know
when EA Sports comes out with the
college football game let's just
simulate them if you're gonna do that so
that part bothered me a little bit
everything else I'm perfectly fine with
fascinated to see what happens this
weekend I believe if you tried to do a
money line parlay for TCU winning and
and USC winning
you're getting like minus 200 on that so
Vegas thinks one of those teams losing
now both of them are favored but both
are favored in in very tight spreads so
something's going to happen is what
Vegas is trying to tell us
okay so let's dive into that talking
with Andy Staples covers college
football for the athletic here on The
Dan Patrick Show Ross Tucker filling in
for Dan who's under the weather got the
call late last night coming off the
bench like I did a lot in the NFL
if TCU loses or if USC loses take them
one at a time please Andy should Ohio
State first of all should Ohio State
jump over them and secondly
do you think they will
I'm not gonna get into should or I don't
know I mean they say four best and it's
the 13 people's opinion of what the four
best is is what's going to happen so if
USC loses to Utah they're out they're
going to put you they're going to put
Ohio State in there the bigger question
is if TCU loses and and then what
happened and then USC wins because
tcub12-1 it would not be a conference
Champion but neither would Ohio State
I think the Big 12 probably deserves
more respect than it's gotten this year
because there were no off days in the
Big 12 pretty much everybody could beat
everybody everybody was pretty good
there were no games you could sleep walk
through and win and if you look at TCU
they've proven they can win in a
multitude of ways they can they can beat
you in a shootout they can fall behind
and come back they can beat you in a
rock fight like they did against Texas
they are a pretty complete team at this
point with a pretty complete resume that
said
if you look back at the committee's
history when they have a controversial
choice between number four and number
five they always pick the team that they
think would win if they play so they say
they don't look at Vegas lines but they
almost always pick the team that would
be favored in Vegas Ohio state would be
favored over TCU or USC
could actually probably before your
favorite over Michigan if they played
again which if you saw the game you're
wondering why the hell that would happen
but
that's what that usually comes down to
it came down to it in 2014 when they
were looking at Ohio State and TCU and
Baylor and guess what they picked right
because Ohio State won the National
Championship it happened in 2017. they
had Alabama sitting there they had Ohio
State sitting there they picked Alabama
guess what Alabama won the national
title
so first of all there's a lot of things
that I have a problem with there if
that's the case and let's just go buy
the Vegas spreads at the start of the
Year and have those four teams be in the
college football playoff but here's my
bigger concern Andy even like USC or TCU
in my mind they shouldn't be penalized
by playing in a conference Championship
game while Ohio State just sits there
that to me seems unfair like on some
level it's almost as if they should
change the system oh wait they already
voted to do that so that's why they're
that's one of the reasons why they're
changing it
the the new system the 12 team playoff
that's coming in
the the conference Championship Game can
actually help you and probably won't
knock you out of the playoff it might
knock you into a road game or it might
knock you out of a buy but it's it's
going to be a situation where you're not
going to be completely just shut out of
the thing if you lose a game that you
didn't somebody texted me last week and
said why why isn't USC just sit this one
out and I was like well because I don't
think USC is going to write the check
for the broadcast write speed of the
Pac-12 championship game that's not
going to be broadcast and the Pac-12 is
not going to do any favors to USC which
is leaving for the Big Ten so you know
that that's not going to happen but your
point is valid and that is why or one of
the reasons why that they are making
these changes
so what is going on there with like the
Rose Bowl and the college football
playoff expansion because I said I saw
something came through recently where
the Rose Bowl finally like signed off on
it or something well they're waiting on
the Rose Bowl to figure out what they
want to do that they want to start this
thing in 2024. they can start it in 2026
because that's when the TV contract runs
out they can do whatever they want at
that point and their contracts with the
bulls will be expired so they can format
it however they want set it up but if
they want to do it early they got to get
all the bowls that are involved now on
board and so the Rose Bowl wants to
start at 2 p.m Pacific Time on January
1st
my my thing to this and I would just
tell the role if I were the people in
charge and and neither side would
actually do this but I would go to the
Rose Bowl and say you can be the
national championship game every year if
you don't like that have a monster truck
rally for All We Care there are lots of
stadiums
and he really appreciate the time thank
you so much for coming on the show you
gotta check out Andy all the great work
he does for the athletic obviously
follow him on social media as well at
Andy Staples and Andy like me really
likes food and tweeting about food and
talking about food so he's a great
follow thank you so much for coming on
the show Andy really appreciate it thank
you Ross
there he is Andy Staples